he is the former democratic senator from
minnesota who now hosts the al
franken podcast al franken
oh look at that
al your your papers are sticking out of
your pocket oh yeah
um oh by the way thanks for the free
covet test
oh sure okay nice our pleasure for
something for later uh
and uh are you nervous i mean it's
election time do you get it
does it get the old juices flowing do
you remember the old days when you had
been flowing for quite a while during
the cycle
uh but you know you know you keep
you have said for two years i think
you're the first one
to say this over two years yeah yeah he
ain't going
what if he won't leave and
my answer to that is that's great
because if he won't leave that means he
lost
and he will be escorted out and i'll
pick him up and take him wherever he
wants to go okay well that's
you know this is what democrats keep
saying and you know democrats have been
wrong about so much
so you excuse me if i'm not so sanguine
as you are about this
but escort it out this is what happens
in other countries we've seen this in
many other countries now we are one of
those countries
maybe i should escort it out what
i i didn't mean i know i'm afraid he'll
steal it if that's what you're talking
about what i'm talking about is
if he says there's easily a scenario
which you can see
where he said he's never going to
concede
so he's going to say all kinds of [ __ ]
about oh
i'm hearing i'm hearing about ballots
i'm hearing about this
and then he has a lot of enablers in
courts and legislatures
okay so it comes to january 20th he's
saying we got to suspend this until we
find out what the hell is going on
and then i know you you guys keep saying
he'll be escorted out by people in the
government
he is the government now january 20th
by the law by the law
which joe biden the scenario happens joe
biden will be
the president at noon he will get taken
escorted out
that's if listen what you're talking
about your dreams
perhaps what you're talking about is the
boogaloo boys and everybody what i'm
talking about is
who at the point that the
commander-in-chief says this election
has been rigged it's
not fair i'm i'm still president until
we figure it out
we don't know what will happen let's
agree to disagree on this yeah we don't
know
but uh look you're one of the few
liberals who the military likes
really you are you you played many us
asia
you're welcome there they trust you they
like you
what's your assessment on if they have
to get involved
the chairman of the joint chiefs of
staff millie
will take him out so you okay
well okay
okay i hope so but you know it may not
come down to him he's it shouldn't
it shouldn't it shouldn't i know lots of
things shouldn't just along the way that
he's going to try to steal it that's why
it is so important for everybody to vote
and i
i won my first election like 312 votes
you know
right you had recounts right i had a
recount they didn't let i didn't get
there till july
and they i won the recount actually
in january but they they did legal stuff
to keep me out
but if it weren't for those 312 votes we
wouldn't have the affordable care act
because i was the 60th vote
so i this is what this was this is what
this was about
this was i want your audience
to go to joebiden.com
call because i know everybody tells me
i'm
so nervous i can't wait till
do something
you